Now that was a lot of code again,
so I'm really going to need some tests to makes sure I got this right.
Rather than write the types of tests that we had before with the search statements,
I'm going to introduce a new type of test.
This comes from the standard Python module called "doctest."
It stands for documentation test.
The idea is that you can write comments--
the sort of comments that go with your class items and with your function items
and then automatically have them run its tests.
The tests look just like something that you would type into the Python interpreter.
The way doctest knows that you've got a test
is you have three-arrow prompt,
and an expression is input and the following lines
are the output that comes back from that expression.
It tests to see if what comes back when you run the test is what was expected.
Here I've typed in what I've done at an interactive session,
what the results should be, and then when I make a change to my program
I can run it again and make sure I haven't messed anything up.
For example, at the start here I just want to test out what are the successors
of the start state with both glasses empty and when one glass has capacity 4
and the other has capacity 9.
In general there are six actions but here a lot of them end up being the same,
because if you pour zero into zero either way or if you empty out either of them,
it all comes out the same.
We only end up with three states, and they happen to have these labels--
(0, 9) filling Y, (0, 0)--we called that emptying Y, but of course emptying 0 gives you 0.
It could have been the no opt, but that's just the way the successor function works out.
Then (4, 0) is filling X.
More interestingly, if you have 3 and 5 and you fill--
so this is testing when we aren't exceeding the capacity,
and this test is when we do exceed the capacity.
We can see they work out to the right numbers.
Then we solve a problem and come up with a solution and so on.
Doctest is a nice capacity to allow you to write tests this way.
You can sprinkle them throughout your program, and then you can run the test.
Just say print doctest.testmod, which stands for test module.
If you give it no arguments, it tests the current module.
When I run this I get the comforting message
that there's a test result that is none of the tests failed, and there were 9 that were attempted.
Let's go back and look at the solution.
I'm asking given glasses of levels 4 and 9 trying to find the goal 6.
This is the shortest solution possible--fill Y, pour from Y into X, empty X, do the same,
empty X again, fill Y into X again, fill Y, and pour from Y into X, and then we end up with a 6 in Y.
We can solve problems more generally.
Here I've defined a function num_actions, which says given an X and Y capacity and a goal
how long does it take to solve the goal--the total number of steps it's going to take.
Then I asked here for all values of X and Y less than 10--for all capacities less than 10--
and for all goals smaller than the capacity,
what's the longest? What's the hardest? Which combinations of those takes the most actions?
The answer was if you're given glasses of size 7 and 9
and asked to pour out 8, that's the hardest problem within that range.